los manifestantes se enfrentaron con la
policía antidisturbios durante la quinta
noche de protestas en barcelona las
autoridades dispararon gases
lacrimógenos en un intento de dispersar
a la multitud
entre los manifestantes destrozaban
ventana saqueaban tiendas e incendiaban
contenedores y motocicletas la ira
inundó las calles por el arresto del
rapero pablo hasél que está en el centro
de una controversia sobre la libertad de
expresión
hazel fue detenido por la policía el
martes luego de un enfrentamiento de 24
horas en un edificio universitario el
hombre de 32 años cumple una condena de
nueve meses de prisión por insultar a la
monarquía española y elogiar el
terrorismo en varias ciudades se han
llevado a cabo protestas
mayoritariamente pacíficas pidiendo su
liberación durante el sábado los
residentes expresaron su frustración por
el daño causado por los disturbios
esto no puede ser estado destruido todo
quemado o el plástico todas las noches
helicópteros ya estamos un poquito
hartos
la verdad yo no violencia no estoy de
acuerdo cuando rompe mediaciones tragos
eso ya no tiene ninguna justificación el
caso ha provocado un debate nacional
sobre la libertad de expresión en medio
de llamadas a un cambio en la denominada
ley mordaza del país el gobierno español
ha anunciado que eliminará las penas de
prisión por delitos relacionados con la
libertad de expresión pero las enmiendas
propuestas no afectarán la sentencia del
rapero